hey guys so I'm giving you guys a first
look at the new Apple iWatch here it is
on my wrist it's very skin-like
it feels really comfortable it's almost
like I'm not wearing anything I'm gonna
do a quick little demo here Jenna if you
can get up I'm gonna push oh that's
that's nice I mean it doesn't work yet
but I have a feeling that's soon when
the server's are online tomorrow after
the big announcement it's gonna start
working let's give it another push Jen
not okay see when you DoubleTap normally
something would happen but yeah you can
see it's it's there it's not raised at
all it's really great okay it's good
another push maybe just give it a okay
give it all that was real hard
let's give it a swipe baby okay yeah I'm
still not in that but it gave one more
okay yeah I think it's really great like
look at this it actually moving swiftly
r skin that's amazing let's see that
again I think that looks that look good
that's a good demo Wow look at that just
scrunches oh that's disgusting